[Music]
mind God connection is something that
people have intuitively known for a long
time but science has only I would say in
the last few years
gotten a grasp and acceptance of this
concept it essentially means that your
brain has intimate connections with the
gut and another entity in our gut the
second brain which is about a hundred
million nerve cells that are sandwiched
in between the layers of the gut and
they can do a lot of things on their own
in terms of regulating our digestive
processes but there's a very intimate
conversation between that little brain a
second brain in the gut and our main
brain they use the same
neurotransmitters they are connected by
nerve pathways and so we have really an
integrated system from our brain to
little brains I got the gut and it goes
in both directions the little brain of
the second brain in the gut you're not
able to to see it because it's as I said
it's a spread out through the entire
length of the gut from your esophagus to
the end of your large intestine several
layers of nerve cells interconnected and
what they do is even if you and you can
do this in in in animal experiments if
you completely disconnect this little
brain in the gut from your main brain
this little brain can completely take
care of all the digestive processes the
contractions peristaltic reflex
regulation of blood flow in the
intestine and it has many sensors so it
knows exactly what's going on inside the
gut what goes on in the wall - got any
distension any chemicals all of this is
being picked up by these sensory nerves
fed into the enteric nervous system the
second brain and then the second brain
generates these stereotypic responses
so when you vomit when you have diarrhea
when you have normal digestion all of
this is encoded in programs in your
second brain but the second brain can't
do it cannot generate any conscious
perceptions or gut feelings that really
is the bill the only ability that that
allows us to do this and perceive all
the stuff that goes on inside of us is
really the big brain and the specific
areas within circuits within the brain
that process information that comes up
from the god still most of that
information is not really consciously
perceived so ninety nine ninety-five
percent of all this massive amount of
information coming from the gut is
processed integrated with other inputs
that the brain gets from the outside
from smell visual stimuli and only a
very small portion is then actually made
conscious so when you feel good after a
meal or when you ate the wrong thing and
you nauseated those are the few
occasions were actually we realize that
we come aware of our gut feelings even
though a lot of other stuff is going on
in this brain gut access all the time
when we talk about the connection
between depression and the gut there's
there's some very intriguing
observations both clinically but also
now more recently scientifically that
make it highly plausible that is an
intimate connection between serotonin
the god sirloin our food depression and
gut function so on a clinical level this
there's a connection because many
patients with depression also complain
of of constipation sore distinct
dysfunction of the of the gut and often
the medications that people with
depression take particularly serotonin
reuptake inhibitors such as Prozac and
and all the other drugs in this category
they often cause transient
gastrointestinal dysfunction so that
that's on the clinical
however what makes it particularly
interesting and still an open question
really more than 95% of all our
serotonin we have in our organism is
really produced and stored in the gut
and specialized cells so called enteral
chromaffin cells so our major by far the
largest store of that molecule they play
such a big role in modulating our mood
and our our well-being also appetite
pain sensitivity is stored in the gut
and a lot of very interesting
discoveries have been made more recently
that makes it even more intriguing so
this serotonin is synthesized in the gut
from precursors that come from our our
food that we ingest and the microbes
that live in the gut are actually able
through chemicals that they produce to
stimulate the production of serotonin
it's been estimated based on study in
animals that 60% of the production is
due to these signals to come from the
microbes that live in our gut so it's in
addition another intriguing finding is
that these serotonin cells so they're
sandwiched in between the cells that
make our lining of the gut one end
sticks into the inside samples
everything that goes on inside the gut
the other side they're interesting li
has an outgrowth which connects it
through a synapse with sensory nerve
endings so many diggle nerve endings so
this is a cell that sticks into the gut
samples a lot of things that go on in
our digestive tract then it produces
serotonin largely through the influence
of microbes that live in our gut and
then the signal when this cell is
activated there's many things chemical
or mechanical stimuli
associate with digestion it signals
through the synapse directly into our
brain through the vagus nerve into
centers that have to do with I mean
ultimately with emotional regulation and
emotion generation so even though we
don't have the proof for that it would
be very difficult to mention that
there's not a significant influence on
our mood and that this system if it's
out of balance does not play a
significant role in in the
pathophysiology of depression
there's many food items that contain no
reactive molecules signaling substances
including oysters
chocolate and in many other foods that
to varying degrees contain either the
precursors of serotonin reaction
serotonin molecules it's possible that
these these contents of this molecule
are the basis for somebody's claimed
effects of food items like oysters as an
aphrodisiac or a mood enhancer like with
chocolate people say they feel a lot
better after they eat their that daily
piece of chocolate in the evening which
is pretty true not just not just from
the taste but from from this chemical
connection
[Music]